janes leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung letzten
sieht verstellung
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich mache
noch eine weile ein killer sieht
gefunden habe der echt krass ließ sich
den sieg einfach kinder wie müller max
müller brauchen lange nicht mehr gehört
jedenfalls ihr müsst gar nichts
umständen einstellungen einfach nur der
sieg ist 51 37 88 93 765 77 91 01
steht doch unten in der beschreibung ich
bin so ein volk erwarte dass nochmals
jetzt aber nur killer also seinen teil
wie das neue welt erstellen so wir
stellen diese welt an das ist eine welt
die für alle gedacht die gerne in den
alten welten spielen und gerne den den
sieg generator von damals sehr geil
finden sage ich mal wir haben nämlich
zwischendurch immer mal ganz ganz ganz
ganz viele höhlen das heißt ich habe mal
ganz kurz hier opfer fackeln
details wir haben ja wirklich überall
hören wo man immer auch tiefer rein kann
ja okay doch ein gutes beispiel
aber wenn man jedenfalls ausgeht sieht
man schon von der kompletten kreation
hier im kompletten links das ist so
unglaublich geil die sind so viele berge
allein dieses loch hier schon zum
beispiel hier sind auch über also hören
einfach in einer wand sowie das einfach
damals minecraft war eine fackel nicht
so gut da müsste ich vielleicht
jedenfalls habe ich halt wirklich
überall hören drehen wir haben allgemein
klasse drehen finde ich das alles
wahnsinn dieser sieht und wir haben es
halt so dass wir wirklich wie damals in
der alpha oder beta eine menge wald
haben und eine menge höhen und tiefen
unterschiede sage ich mal das heißt wir
haben hier im wald keine erhebung können
hier runter dann gibt's hier wieder so
ein bisschen kleiner lang also sich
jetzt kein ziel wertingen krass viele
diamanten sind oder so sondern ihr wollt
ihr dass ich mal coole landschaft
vorstellen mit dem einfach so spielen
kann
deswegen mache ich das jetzt mal einfach
damit zum beispiel höhle und was ich
auch sein als findet das was ich hier
gleich generieren wird da wo er gerade
noch einen zeh also erstmal überblick na
das sieht alles halt relativ krass nach
einfach nach der alten beta nach der
alten version aus und wir haben hier
halt auch nicht schädigen überweg also
hörte ich dass die welt sich mal kurz
aufbauen also das alles sieht einfach so
aus wie wirklich damals wenn wir eine
riesige waldfläche das seht ihr schon
wir haben ganz vereinzelt
höhenunterschieden haben da hinten berge
wir haben hier so berge mit sein
durchgang über ganz teil also man kann
hier wird sicher etwas richtig schönes
bauen wie immer wenn ihr in den
vorstellungen meine sie zunehmend etwas
cooles darauf baut dann nicht irgendwie
total scheiße als ich mir jetzt nicht
den scheiß anhält crafting twitter schon
wieder und akzeptieren wenn ihr was cool
ist ausbauten im video antwort an
jedenfalls habe mich auch vom chilligen
übergegangen also das ist auf jeden fall
total geil da oben haben auch kürbisse
und alles da kann man mit sicherheit da
oben was richtig schilling ist drauf
bauen dann mit dem berg hier unten
verbinden also hier ist ja gemeinsam
unterricht langgezogener berg das sieht
man ja dass die spitze da geht es runter
laut flach das dann so langsam ab
erwartet so langsam also da hinten flach
das ab meine ich hier ist ja relativ
steil
hier haben wir halt quasi nur wald die
haben ein bisschen ganz normale berge
das liegt aber ganz kurzen sechs selbst
einen wehrte verlängern im habe ganz
normale berge das sieht man schon daran
dass das gras auch einen ganz anderen
ton an als also dass gerade hier ist
natürlich grauer als das satte gras da
unten oder besseres beispiel da vorne
sieht man hier direkt den unterschied
allerdings ist man hier so auf der höhe
mit den anderen ebenen und das auf jeden
fall auf ganz cool man kann das auch
alles irgendwie verbinden
also es ist wirklich ein unglaublich
genial aussieht wenn man einfach nur
minecraft zocken will muss sich mit ganz
viel tamtam
wenn man dann allerdings auch noch ein
bisschen was special guests abend will
er kann man einfach in diese richtung
fliegen und zwar zu den koordinaten -
270 also da muss ich ein bisschen ruhe
bewahrt
294 so hat er jetzt einfach immer
geradeaus bis man bei z - 170 ist also
nicht 170 wo ich gerade bei sondern
einfach - 170 dann sehen wir dass
nämlich gleich das gerade fette wolke
beim ich hab jetzt über die shader
eingepackt aber in ihrem heute hate
vorstellungen chainrai danke
er habe auch noch mal so eine coole ecke
fällt auf wie kann man sich auf jeden
fall auch noch hin bauen sieht auch sehr
schön aus hier auf einen sehr viel mit
will dir also es gibt ja auf jeden fall
wunderbare ecken wo man sich einfach hin
man kann schön blauer himmel genauso wie
bei mir draußen auf blauer himmel schön
gerade erst mal draußen eingeklemmt
sonnenbrand geholt keller als er noch
zwischendurch immer ein paar
schluchten sehr wenige aber wir haben
welche und da vorne gleich leuchten
kommt sie auf uns zu
besonders schön wenn ich bei der
pyramide diesem weg von hier
weil man hat behindert und diesen killer
sonnenaufgang und so sonne gemeinde
plant sie wissen ich bin ja ein sehr ein
wert ambiente oder mensch so haben wir
zwar keine geilen sachen drin also die
welt sich sogar sind halt normale sachen
gegen die kiste oder so aber wir halt
schon gesagt wenn ihr einfach nur
minecraft spielen wollt dann ist es
perfekt und ihr habt jetzt hier auch
keine mega sachen drin sondern einfach
zehn goldbarren 16 eisenwaren 26 knochen
und zehn verrottetes fleisch also das
wäre wirklich einfach nur minecraft ist
es genau das richtige für euch mal
direkt auf die sonne zu und mit diesem
schönen blick einfach auf diese
wunderschöne für amiga und diese samt
position hätte ich aber nicht gesehen
wenn dann noch zeit ist dass kellan
lieber nicht essen vermerkt besser noch
drin
wir müssen hier noch ein russischer gar
nicht statt mit ihrer einkommen
mensch muss ich ja wirklich nicht na gut
ach so ja doch das wusste ich ja ja
heute übrigens keine fans kämpfen weil
ich echt das mit dem sonnenbad fitness
first winterstars presse ich würde sagen
es euch gefallen hat dann würde ich mich
über einen daumen hoch freuen
das zeigt mir dass e mails sieht
vorstellungen wollte er sieht gefallen
hat und was ihr wollt ihr könnt noch
weiterhin sieht es in die kommentare
schreiben
dieser sieht aber jetzt wieder von
dieser von dieser idee hatte ich die
welt hatte ich nämlich in die wehr
stellt vor zwei drei wochen oder so
bewegen wie könnten allerdings weiter
sieht senden und wenn euer sieht dann
schon genannt wurde oder ihr ins lied
gut findet er in der beschreibung hier
könnte auch einfach hoch wollten mit der
positiven bewertungsfunktion und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal tschüss